The Scottish King Duncan learned that his two generals had defeated invading armies.
After the battles, the generals Macbeth and Banquo, encountered three witches.
They made a prophecy that Macbeth would be crowned King of Scotland.
They also prophesied that Banquo's sons would become Scottish kings, but not him.
Macbeth thought that their prophecy might be true, but he was uncertain what to expect.
He invited King Duncan to his castle at Inverness for dinner.
Lady Macbeth persuaded her husband to kill Duncan that very night, by stabbing him.
She was certain the prophecy would come true.
They got Duncan's two royal servants drunk and blamed the murder on them.
Macbeth killed them to avenge the king's death and become king himself.
But he feared that Banquo's sons would seize his crown, as prophesied.
Macbeth planned to kill Banquo and his son Fleance.
Banquo was killed but Fleance escaped.
At an evening banquet, Banquo's ghost visited Macbeth,...
...and he cried out in front of many noble guests.
Frightened, Macbeth went to visit the witches.
There, they told him of more prophecies.
One was that he had to beware of MacDuff,...
...a Scottish nobleman who opposed his succession to the crown.
So Macbeth seized his castle and killed his family, while MacDuff stayed in England.
MacDuff led the English army against Macbeth.
Lady Macbeth killed herself, after ongoing nightmares.
Macbeth and MacDuff met on the battlefield and MacDuff finally killed Macbeth.
Then, Prince Malcolm, son of Duncan, became the King of Scotland.